a lot of people talk about 1917 it's the  front runner one of the frontrunners for  best film and one thing that everybody  raves about with 1917 is the way the  movie looks like it was all done in one  long shot the entire movie just one long  shot that just keeps going and going now  I have to say I liked 1917 but I feel  like their commitment to the whole  one-shot idea sometimes hurt the movie  take a look at this scene where the  British soldier Scofield is running from  German gunfire through a bombed out City  I think the one shot thing I don't know  you take a look  George what are you doing get back in  there  piss off I'm running five hours straight  without a bribe you know they're using  real rats in there I swear those are  real bullets a sweat  [Applause]  George I'm coming all right  that's where you guys come in to see the  show by the way I had to walk through an  Oscar winners urine  [Laughter]